at national heroes square once known as
trafalgar square change was again coming
the prince of wales arriving to witness
the ceremony as barbados said goodbye to
the queen
this was the final time after nearly 400
years that a royal would oversee a
military parade in this way
the moment had come
the queen's standard was lowered and
then the countdown to midnight
barbados no longer a realm now a
republic
[Applause]
the new president dame sandra mason was
sworn in
to pledge your allegiance was prime
minister mia motley who's pushed so hard
for this new stage of independence
as those ties were cut
prince charles formally acknowledged the
pain of the past
from the darkest days
of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
the people of this island
forged their path with extraordinary
fortitude
but for those who've waited so long for
this they still want more
we want
tangible
actions towards reparations for our
people
for our nation and our country we have
we have endured a lot we have still
enjoyed the legacy of the enslaved
period covid meant that large crowds
were kept out and many are still divided
about what this really means
i think there should have been a public
vote
and i think it should have been decided
by the people and not by a few mps
everybody's out
celebrating
feeling proud
the royal family have always said this
was a decision for the people of
barbados after all they have been
independent since the 1960s and the
queen's role has largely been ceremonial
but this certainly is not the royal
family entirely stepping away they will
still be front and center when it comes
to maintaining those connections and
shaping that new relationship
rihanna was a surprise guest
this is a new chapter described by some
as a full stop on their colonial past
now two women at the helm writing their
future
rhiannon mills sky news in bridgetown
[Music]